all right james
james where'd you grow up where are you
from originally garden city new york
and uh tell me about your family growing
up you had both your parents
both my parents were still married i
have four little brothers four little
sisters
how did you describe your childhood
i am the luckiest
and i was the most ungrateful piece of
[ __ ] for a long time
but my childhood was awesome and i'm
i have so many friends that don't have
anything
that's how it was amazing i have two
parents that love me
you know like
i have a brother
my baby brother
he graduated from an ivy league school
in two and a half years
and you know what my mom tells her
friends
james is by far
the smartest of all my children
i got a ged
you graduated high school
i didn't i got a ged yeah through the
ged
when did you drop
out i get kicked out
at what what point
11th grade
so your parents your family loved you
anything else go on in your childhood
that uh
my uncle avoid worships
i worshiped him i watched him i used to
cry my little
you know
abused he had a boat and there'd be all
the other kids on the boat and like we'd
have to go back to nassau county while
they were in suffolk i'd be like let me
stay with jim and
i'd be so jealous that all the other
kids got to stay with him
and i had to go back and i'd cry and you
know
and then i thought he just thought i was
the coolest kid in the world did you let
me drink he let me do drugs
he got synchrogenesis you
got and then you got a recording studio
got me my first guitar
and i told you just because she had bad
love for me but you know
when i pass out you'd have his way with
me
and now i got a
settlement against the diocese of
rockville center for 10 million dollars
and
he was i
i used to keep six of it he was part of
the church he was a priest
you all your uncle was a priest
i'm named after him he's my godfather
james clifford miller father james
clifford miller i'm james willard miller
it happened to you look it up was john
uh uh
saint john's the baptist
were you
this went on from when i was 11 to 13
11 to 14.
and then one
like after he was already in trouble
like
my parent my grandparents were in
florida when they were still alive
and we were there and like i woke up to
his finger like sliding in my butt
and it just it broke me because this is
usually my hair is my idol and like
i don't hate him i love him which makes
me feel even more like a freak
like i i
i had to go to psychiatrists over this
and talk like you know
do you feel like that that event kind of
derails your your whole life after after
it happens
it
changed everything man i got
when i was 14 years old i rented out the
basement of garden city pizza and i had
all my bands equipment down there
a 14 year old kid you know what i'm
saying because my friend can't she was a
senior
i was a freshman
and like i kept trying to [ __ ] her
and uh she was going out this dude named
frank celesco who's my best friends of
this day
he's like you little [ __ ] pumpkin
and you freshman
[ __ ] trying to [ __ ] my garlic
but uh
i take a bullet for him i take a boat
for him in a second
and he'd take a boat from me in a second
the drug you started for you what age
huh drug use started for you at what age
my mom put me on a riddle when i was
seven
and
then i got a while and they usually
started putting me in psychiatric
hospitals and
then dextrine then clonidine
and prozac neuron paxo
you know
and then i found xanax and klonopins i
was like i like these ones i'll take
these ones and she was like no i don't
want you on those ones
i was like you're the one that's tried
to put me on medication my whole life
these ones actually get rid of my
anxiety
my mom's an awesome person i'm not
like she's a recovering addict um
she was [ __ ] up for years she's been
clean for like 17 years now
how do you know
43 43.
so what is your drug today
alcohol
and benzos
but benzers i wouldn't even say that's
my joy like like like
i
like to take four milligrams of
kilometers to ease my anxiety
i was on the phone with dr heinz this
morning and she was like
listen she's like you are definitely um
what'd she say she said
you have severe depression
severe anxiety
and what was the other thing she said
it's very anxiety and uh
ptsd she said however she said i don't
think you're bipolar
i said no i don't think i'm bipolar
either
like
i've just been through the wringer like
and yet you were loved by your parents
but
your uncle kind of
you know my dad said my dad said he
wishes my uncle was still alive so he
could put a bullet on his head
you never said anything to anyone when
it was going on
huh you never said anything to anyone
when it was going on
frank my best friend is the only person
i told
why do you think you never said anything
to your parents
you always i didn't want to hurt jim
i was so confused because he did so many
good things for me but like
you know and like
when i was in sea field rehab about four
years ago like i when she went to my
counselor's office and i just broke down
and started crying i was like you gotta
get my mom up here
my mom started crying sergey she's like
i've been waiting for this phone call
for 25 years
and uh
if i was later
she's like do you think you can make it
here in five hours my mom's like i'm in
the parking lot already
she's like i've been sitting here like
i am so
grateful that i have what i have
i have so many people that love me that
really truly care about me and that will
not give up on me no matter what
[Music]
i mean there was a point where i was so
selfish like i was i was gonna take my
own life and then i was like wait a
minute i can't
i can't do that to my family like i
can't
i'm not a selfish person i'm not
i would never
ever no matter how bad things you got i
would never do that to my family go to
my dad and say dad
i'm gonna kill myself help
like you know
so if you get a settlement from the
church
oh i'm getting a sentiment yeah it's
already it's already done sentence own
are you receiving the money yet
um i've been waiting since
september of 2018 and they told me to
take up to four years
interesting
that'll change your life
right yeah it'll either fix it or
destroy it
it's going to fix it
it's going to fix it sounds like a lot
of money
but you've lived on the streets before
i lived on the street for years
for years
how do you support yourself when you're
living like that
i was shooting dope i'm so dope i
don't know the things i'd rather not
chant i'm sure you know what i'm talking
about
um
i would search the grounds and
you'd be surprised how much do you find
on the ground
about three months ago on 14th and third
there was this green bag turned upside
down and something told me just go look
in it and i looked and it was this
envelope and it was thick
and i turned it over and there was like
this see-through thing and it was built
and so i just put it in my pocket and i
want a few blocks
went down these stairs
there was 900 bucks in the envelope
you know it had no name on it or nothing
so like
um
i found a diamond ring once
um
1998
when i was
really [ __ ] up on shooting coke
i was kicking leaves
out of the curbs on uh
third street in avenue c and i felt
something real and i picked it and there
was this huge bag like this
with all these bags of meat like this in
it
um
i'm a tattoo artist
you know
i ordered one tattoo kid off a wish and
they ended up ripping me off like crazy
and they sent me 30 kits
best thing that could have ever happened
to me
because now
like i a whole bunch of my boys who are
amazing artists i gave them a bunch of
kids
like it's going to be my business and
remember kj who's the most amazing
artist in the universe
i was like no no dude like did you
he said no no no he said well you don't
understand he said i don't care
he said whatever i make you're getting
half of every single time i said no i
will not accept it
this settlement for you is going to
change everything though
just be careful with what it can do for
you
or to you
i'm just i'm not going to take
i'm not gonna let people take advantage
of me i know my real friends are and uh
i'm just gonna stick very close to them
and i am gonna buy an extra place
like
you know i'm gonna grab a lot of these
people that
don't deserve to be out here that are
good people
yeah you gotta fix yourself first
but that's that that is what fixes me
me helping people like
it it takes my mind off my focus like
i don't know i just try to be a good
person and
you have dreams of doing something with
your life when you're young
what do you want to do
musician
you want to hear a song i wrote for my
boy danny who died
can you show me that you can play it for
me later
when we're done
you have friends other than your best
friend you mentioned
frank cajun nick
ralph
matt
i
listen if you can count five
real friends on one hand you're very
lucky i can literally count 20 real
friends
these are people you met on the street
frank i've known since i was 13.
um
girl who lost my virginity to
we're best friends to this day
we are best friends to this day
my ex-girlfriend cat she's a super model
she's been the max magazine she's been
inventory secrets she's been to easter
island
all over europe
uh we're good's friends still
yeah do you have kids
no
okay
no
what's your biggest regret
my biggest regret
losing cat
because laura doesn't want to be with me
anymore
even more than that just
this is cat this is cat right here
she's amazing bro she uh
she bursts
children like underwater for a living
that's your job
if you look up catherine mariville
photography
you'll see her with like probably babies
with umbilical cords attached to the
woman like
she just had her own baby with her
husband
and the way she i just started crying
i'm so happy for her like she's
the best she's amazing
and she's so
gorgeous and
she's like i hate that people
like me for my looks like like why can't
they look at me for like
you know she's a real person
can you keep it down the drink please oh
i'm sorry bro it's just such a red
bright drink
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
love
love just just
love
love just
love is the answer to everything
i think
can't argue with that because hate
i don't want to hate anybody but there
is one person in this life that i hate
and i really do hate him
and i hope he dies because he's an evil
evil human being
he's that age for 30 years
he used to go out with my friend amy
he shared needles with her he had sex
with her without condoms and didn't tell
her she ended up catching it and she
hung herself
and then one day i'm walking up and this
i was messing around with this girl
alicia at the time
and she said james i know i've been real
[ __ ] but please she's like i'm so
scared right now she's like i just shot
call which is doing this bathroom
and he tried to rape me
he just blew my pants down he was like a
little [ __ ] tight little bottle
i said give me your
hands he grabs it by the hand i started
walking away with her and he started
screaming oh i see he was cocky on you
now
and now every time i'm banning like they
go run up behind me and kick me in the
back of the head
but if we come face on face like i'll be
like go around like
i have a lot of regrets
i have a lot of regrets man i've done so
many things wrong not the right way
all right james well thank you so much
for sharing your story
i wish you the best of luck with your
settlement
just be careful with it
i'm gonna
i'm gonna you know